hello and welcome to this video playing
international master Indian King okay
venkatesh columns are one on our very
stylish names but incredibly difficult
to pronounce for Europeans so a declined
bank of we have here with neither three
should be sound the line that I feel is
very okay for black Bishop g5 it looks
weird actually in this combination
because the d5 corn looks very very much
undefended or badly defended band is
supported so on even e6 comes into
consideration here but also g6 yeah g6
maybe for more pressure here on that on
c3
so I get to it gives me that pawn and
give up canceling rights and you're okay
Jack Bishop a six now with the tempo and
then back with this on hmm can also just
drop the bishop back or the six a couple
of moves that make sense queen bee three
I'll ever have to be aware of okay this
is important okay let's retreat this
first so I've snatched this pawn but I
have a little bit of a development
problem so this is quite quite clear
maybe you will play Bishop e7 here yeah
that's a funny idea could be effective
I'm not quite sure about it maybe I can
just do this and take it take it next
so um yeah probably grab it what's going
on here i can i can now take here and go
D 5 D 51 m can also just take it i'm in
rugby 5 is would be 523 it's not
completely clear it's not completely
clear so let's do this
hey I can take only seven with the Queen
a queen c720 sound sorry yeah I'm not
quite sure if we can do something
against this may be Queen 86 Queen d6
that was stronger actually there was a
bit stronger to push the King to g1 even
that would have been now King it to
maybe and if I am if I take here twice
he will come to be seven this is a
little bit awkward anyway I have the
same age 65 check check check I should
have paid more attention you already I
relaxed too early but you still somewhat
still a little bit tricky but it's night
is so awful probably it's not a big
problem
so how to do this King c 6 p-7 maybe
trying to try to enter on the second i
can check in Bishop's III jack and I'm
going to quite sure where I go after
that to be honest hmm okay maybe that
wasn't all that clever I should have
thought about this a little bit this is
a little bit awkward
time warning
check I have sport disc this is stuffs
unbelievable I really manages again
check
check okay check check too late hey I
want to silly end to this game I mean it
got the result that should have had
after after ninety percent of the game
but yeah I just I just did my usual
thing I didn't pay any attention after
having a complete win on the board yeah
I mean it's okay up to this point I
think maybe I had something stronger
before this is like yeah a complete win
and it's okay up to here and here i
didn't i didn't really see this move
coming and this is entirely stupid i can
just take still take g2a to end and win
easily and it's just you but just this
is just very bad and also i can take
here for this and yeah and it's just
over yeah he played the opening in a
very strange way Bishop g5 and Bishop h4
is just pretty bad because white them
simply yet doesn't pay attention to
what's going on like here Bishop g7 in
the d5 pawn is weak so black was already
better out of the opening winning an
important pawn yeah g6 this is this is
interesting but I'm not really sure that
it is doing all that much you know
computer basically says I'm winning and
it wants to just take you seven oh no
it's okay it agrees that d5 is
interesting okay Queen takes a two now
by the engine hi ok and the computers is
mercy listen maybe a looks a bit strange
to have this pawn there but yeah yeah
doesn't have a good square you know can
always a Tekkit yeah okay that's much
easier than my retreat check check Oh
okay i have to have to play king e7 here
here Queen a six would be awkward yeah
this is equal according to the engine
room but it's a very tough position and
so there's 27 was a blunder Jan this is
no everything is is okay again yeah but
I just have to pay more attention the
technical part of the game when I'm
basically have it in the bag but it
still have to find some decent moves ok
guys thanks for watching